[Music]
acting in comedy is in the blood of
Damon Wayans Jr he is the oldest child
of entertainer Damon Wayans senior there
they go ah that's cute oh look at that
and following in his father's footsteps
he made a name for himself with his
roles in the popular sitcoms happy
endings a new girl now he stars in the
new CBS comedy it's called Happy
Together remember that song Wayans Jr
plays Jake and accountants life as well
turned upside down when a famous rock
star unexpectedly moves in with him and
his wife in this preview got funny moves
Jake and Claire are attempting to rid
their home of all their old belongings
well what is this giant elastic band for
really big accounting documents Claire
if you must know this is my elastic
blaster exercise band allow me to
demonstrate I simply put this in the
wedge of the door right close said door
put it around said body oh look at all
that resistance huh look at that see
back when I play college ball this is
how I used to explode through the lane
I'd be like
and it's a great way to practice being
held back in a fight table good morning
you have to do that or was that a one
take only 17 times oh yeah they got a
lot of footage of me just looking like
an idiot when we think of the Wayans
family there's so many how many Wayans
are there there are a lot of Wayans I
think there's like 50 51 but it's really
that's what I wonder about with the
Wayans family and everybody mostly are
in entertainment right so did you say I
want to do this or did you try to do
everything you can to stay away from it
initially I did everything I could to
stay away from it I wanted to be an
animator growing up so I used to draw
all the time I went to college for art
for like a year and and then I just kind
of got bit by the bug and you know I
like to pitch jokes and and that started
my writing career then I did stand-up
that is interacting and it's in front of
a live audience you like yeah yeah I
love it I love it because because it's
so much like stand-up it's that either
that instant gratification or instant
judgment you know like some jokes will
work and kill other jokes you know it
instantly oh yeah every action you do
and you doing it and it's really funny
now that's something that I had to learn
since this is my first live audience had
to learn to hold for the laughs if
you'll have your line that you want to
say and then people aren't laughing so
you have to wait so it's like not as
natural as it yeah right and you have to
learn to wait and then when you dramatic
pause playing the show I like the
conceit of the whole show be together
right based on a true story yeah it's
it's I'm told to say it's loosely
inspired by okay the true story of the
creator of the show Ben Winston this
happened to him
Harry Styles from one direction erection
moved
in with Ben Winston and his wife for
like we're supposed to be two weeks went
up being two years we stayed in his
attic so that's pretty I mean I just saw
our story there yeah but then you know
ever very tight yeah but anything past
that is just fiction you know cuz you
know Ben's been that's why he's not a
black dude yeah
and so yeah so so the show is a
30-something couple married couple who
was live to get turned upside down with
an international pop star moves in and
my characters the accountants right not
just some random dude coming in to have
some accountant in you I mean you know
were you like is that totally yeah that
is that it's not me I'm not I was good
at math and high school but that's like
where I draw the line like I don't
really know how to crunch numbers now
Damon used to always use you and your
siblings in his standard right we heard
a lot about your life growing up you're
a father of five yeah you use your kids
in your routine I have one bit about my
boy who you know he the youngest one and
he's uh but aside from that I don't I
don't do this because you know I mean I
don't know my dad did it without asking
me he just like at least when I give
mine the opportunity to like be able to
you know say like whether or not they
want me to talk about them yeah and what
is your dad make of this show oh he
loves it he loves it he's actually gonna
be on one of the episodes
yeah my dad maybe so how did he work
with that kind of a stretch I don't know
it was hard it was hard I was really
like trying to be like okay so is he
playing my dad in real life or just in
the show and and so we you know we we
had a good time we always have a good
time together
now he's reported that he's leaving
lethal weapon is that true he's leaving
the show I don't know I don't know I saw
the video yeah like dad that's bizarre
yeah I don't know he might be I don't
know if the show if the show goes out
the air he's obviously leaving yeah no I
I heard that he decided to step away but
I'm really you decide to do that yeah
would be like
I'm excited for you though because I
love the premise Ben and Harry are great
and I would just think that there's a
lot of material there for you to play
with yeah there is there is the your
wife on the show also good I love that I
love that was one of the things that
drew me to the show was the fact that
it's a couple who enjoyed other's
company yeah they have so many times in
shows you just see them people putting
up with each other for the kids or
wanting to divorce this couple actually
enjoys time with each other and then
this pop star comes in and just
heightens the happiness airs Mondays at
8:30 7:30 central right here where Damon
Wayans Jr on CBS